[Music]
in 1990 the Italian government enlisted
top engineers to stabilize pz's famous
leaning tower there had been many
attempts to write the tower during its
eight hundred year history but this
team's computer models revealed the
urgency of their situation they
projected the tower would topple if it
reached an angle of five point four four
degrees and it was currently leaning at
five point five no one knew how the
tower was still standing but the crisis
was clear they had to solve a problem
that stumped centuries of Engineers and
they needed to do it fast to understand
their situation it's helpful to
understand why the tower tilted in the
first place in the 12th century the
wealthy maritime Republic of Pisa set
about turning its Cathedral square into
a magnificent landmark workers
embellished and enlarged the existing
church and added a massive domed
baptistry to the plaza in 1173
construction began on a free-standing
company lay or bell tower the engineers
and architects of the time were masters
of their craft but for all their
engineering knowledge they knew far less
about the ground they stood on pieces
name comes from a Greek word for marshy
land which perfectly describes the clay
mud and wet sand below the city's
surface ancient Romans counteracted
similar conditions with massive stone
pillars called piles which rest on
earth's stable bedrock however the
towers architects believed a three metre
foundation would suffice
for their relatively short structure
unfortunately for them less than five
later the towers southern side was
already underground such a shifting
foundation would normally have been a
fatal flaw if workers added more weight
the pressure from upper storeys would
sink the structure and fatally increase
the lien but construction halted at the
fourth storey for nearly a century as
Pisa descended into prolonged warfare
this long pause allowed the soil to
settle and when construction began again
in 1272 the foundation was on slightly
more stable footing under the direction
of architect Giovanni di Simone a
workers compensation for the towers
minor tilt by making the next few floors
taller on the southern side but the
weight of the extra masonry made that
site sink even deeper by the time they
completed the seventh floor and bell
chamber the angle of the tilt was 1.6
degrees for centuries engineers tried
numerous strategies to address the lien
in 1838 they dug a walkway around the
base to examine the sunken foundation
but removing the supporting sand only
worsened the tilt in 1935 the Italian
Corps of Engineers injected mortar to
strengthen the base however the mortar
wasn't evenly distributed throughout the
foundation resulting in another sudden
drop all these failed attempts along
with the ever sinking foundation moved
the tower closer to its tipping point
and without definitive knowledge of the
soil composition engineers couldn't
pinpoint the towers fatal angle or
devised a way to stop its fall in the
years following World War two
researchers developed tests to identify
those missing variables and in the 1970s
engineers calculated the curved towers
center
of gravity with this data and new
computing technology engineers could
model how stiff the soil was the towers
trajectory and the exact amount of
excavation needed for the tower to
remain standing
in 1992 the team drilled diagonal
tunnels to remove 38 cubic meters of
soil from under the towers in North End
then they temporarily counterbalance the
structure with 600 tons of lead ingots
before anchoring the base with steel
cables more than six centuries after its
construction the tower was finally
straightened to a tilt of about four
degrees no one wanted the tower to fall
but they also didn't want to lose the
landmarks most famous feature today the
tower stands at 55 or 56 meters tall and
it should remain stable for at least 300
years as a monument to the beauty of
imperfection
[Music]
interested in architecture and design
take a closer look at the science behind
the world's tallest buildings or learn
from one of nature's greatest architects
bees they might just convince you that
hexagons are the perfect shape
[Music]